all right welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show after 18 seasons in the NBA where
he earned the reputation of being one of
the best buzzer-beating shot makers in
the history of the Association and a few
seasons on the sideline as the coach of
the New York Knicks he is now member of
the Dancing with the Stars cast of 2017
good to see you Derek Fisher new team it
is a new team yeah how how did you come
about to do the the dancing um Derek
yeah just life I mean you know after 20
years basically being in the NBA and
playing and coaching and not having time
or even the desire to explore these
other things another opportunities your
timing and life just kind of connected
and Here I am now now the competitive
juices though do flow always well I mean
cuz you know I have I have worked with
Emmitt Smith Kurt Warner Warren Sapp
Michael Irvin and I don't believe I'm
missing anybody Jerry Rice mmm they've
all done this mm-hm and they all say
that it's Irvin my gosh
they all say that this is serious
business when it gets down to it yeah
I'm not too Mannion yeah yeah it's a lot
of fun it's hard work right and you for
sure like it and we haven't started yet
or the premier will be next week yes but
once it turns into a competition up I
have no doubt that you'll want to win
badly all the shades are going down it's
what you're saying I'm gonna try my best
no no no come on now no I know I know
it's always been humble you know but I
mean tio is gonna be in this mix yeah
he's not gonna be humble about any Tio's
if he has a humble oh aspect to him that
people don't oh oh I know I know he's
been on this show many times he's got
he's got that going but when it comes
down to the competition yeah yes great
footwork though which is so important to
this show shot I think he'll do well I
haven't seen him you know practicing yet
but I think he'll do well I think
there's no question he is going to at
least if I was him mm-hmm he would bring
a star out
put it in the middle of the floor and do
a number on a star just like you did
with the 49ers and see that's where
we'll have a problem
one is teyla and i have a great
relationship but I'm a Cowboys fan is
that right and if I didn't even know
that tries to bring a star out and do a
dance over the top it's gonna be a fight
on this you'll be so you're seeing
you'll be the George Teague of that
situation yes I will be George is he
gonna comment below that thing I loved
every moment of it which is before I
knew too yo but I literally love seeing
George that are you throwing are you
from the Metroplex area I'm from I'm
born and raised in Little Rock okay
so Jerry Jones and Jimmie Johnson went
to the U of A and so they have a rich
history with the state and I grew up
kind of knowing their story and then
followed you know Jerry Jones to Dallas
and ninja Matt Johnson came to coach
later so I've been with the Cowboys
since 89 one in 15 and you know riding
ever since Irvin yeah for sure you know
that's right our van was there and the
one in 15 Meghan Troy and then then
Emmitt comes and then the rest is
literally history yeah Derek Fisher here
on the Rich Eisen show all right let's
talk some hoops before we return to to
dancing your shot making ability with
mere seconds to go is there something
that you could explain about your
clarity of moment in those moments like
that game 5 in the Western Conference
semifinals against the Spurs back in Oh
4 or the Oh 9 NBA Finals that game for I
mean is there something similar to these
moments that you're able allowed you to
make those shots
I mean for me the similarities are just
did I always approach those moments with
the same clarity and focus I tried to
give to practice and shoot around and
preseason and regular season is that you
know whenever the game is is going until
this over is not over and there was
something about in particular in San
Antonio you know we were up 15 in that
game I think at one point 71 of 56 or
something like that whatever type of run
they made Duncan makes a shot and even
if you see during the timeout like I'm
sitting there and I'm pissed that we've
allowed them to come back and take the
lead but in my mind I'm still thinking
there's enough time for something to
happen I played a game in college we
were down by one point with 0.2 seconds
left Arkansas Little Rock at Mississippi
State and I'm taking the ball out of
bounds on the baseline I make eye
contact with my teammate and point him
to the rim that way he spins out to the
front of the rim I throw the ball he
tips him we win the game at Mississippi
State so those experiences for me yeah
taught me that as long as there's time
on the clock you can figure something
out and just but in the moment when the
shots going up you don't think anything
about it you don't think I want it you
don't think anything of that not I I
want those opportunities sure um I play
with some of the greatest players to
ever play the game
and so those opportunities were a few
far between rightfully so because Kobe
Bryant and Shaquille in PAL Gasol etc
those guys deserved those opportunities
we got it you got to bring Orion to that
mix - yeah of course I mean you know
Robert he's the king of those shots as
well yeah I think long with you
you know Rob's because it was on a few
different teams like then sometimes
people forget you know how big of a shot
maker he was because he did in Houston
and LA and San Antonio but for me I
always wanted to be in those
opportunities and those those situations
so when they did come I mean I figured I
might as well try to make it Derek
Fisher here on the Rich Eisen show day
after it's announced that Kobe's gonna
get his number with numbers 8 and 24
going in the rafters with the Warriors
in the house that'll be an interesting
night
what was it I mean you you were there
for the entirety in a way of his
transformation you were there for
everything yeah where it was with Jack
and then you were there when he was in
his own personal troubles and then when
everything was moving on and he wanted
to be the man I mean you were there for
all about what was it like being
alongside watching that Derek um I'm I'm
always amazed even cuz I don't talk
about these things you know at dinner
with my friends and we're just
about Lakers in history but that's why
you come on the Richard exactly so when
Rich Eisen asked me about these folks
I'm always amazed at what Kobe was able
to accomplish and even though I was
right next to him and had a front-row
seat
a lot of times it until you look back at
it and really understand what he was
able to do I don't think you fully
appreciate it
to be a high school graduate only a few
months before and literally show up to
the Association already decided that he
was going to be one of the greatest to
ever play the game and then to have the
type of career he had on the court
accomplished what he accomplished have
the ups and downs personally privately
publicly however you want to describe it
but still be able to hold on to this
idea that I'm going to be one of the
greatest to ever do this by the time I'm
finished with it the level of focus and
discipline that that takes is remarkable
and I just I'm always amazed and kind of
humbled in the sense of like I got a
chance to be around there for a long
time well you always here though it was
it's it's not easy being his teammate
either and then he got the rep towards
the end of his career that people didn't
flat-out didn't want to come play with
him and I'm wondering what you say when
you hear that Derek I I agree to the
standpoint of it's not easy but it's not
supposed to be easy when you're trying
to be great
and then when you think about like we're
all waking up every day trying to be you
know above average is something and this
guy was waking up every day wanting to
be the greatest basketball player to
ever touch the earth that's a different
level of thinking and for me it wasn't
easy at all at all times but I just
don't think that anything that is great
is easy so people who tried to I think
it's easy to blame Kobe for things and
put a lot on him to say it wasn't easy
to play with him so therefore then that
absolves some people of their
responsibility that they have to the
team to be the best version of
themselves so why would we be mad at him
for literally always wanting to be
best of himself and didn't expect that
from you so he and I never had many
issues because I always wanted to be the
best I could be for the team and that's
all he was trying to do yeah I mean
Derek Fisher here in the Rich Eisen show
the same people that I said that I
worked with and thus have that
competitive edge when it comes to
dancing mm-hmm
are the same people who are in Pro
Football Hall of Fame
jackets and busts etc because of exactly
what we're talking about here that they
don't suffer fools gladly at all that
they have problems with people who don't
come to work every day with the 24/7 365
mind set to be great right that's why a
lot of them don't coach - right because
it's very difficult yeah to be able to
coach somebody up when you're upset that
they don't get it right from bedtime to
sunrise
yeah and then everything in between
right is well what I mean so can you
give me a moment where a Kobe was a
little bit in somebody's face and they
couldn't handle it you don't have to
give me a name
but where you saw that type of moment
with Kobe now I'm not really the guys
couldn't handle it I just think that it
made people uncomfortable at times like
because nobody else was doing that to
them so then what about Phil being the
coach with Kobe what would it what just
like where he's the coach yeah and and
trying to corral that talent on set yeah
in a way to me it we the stuff that we
experienced was not much different than
to me most great teams or great
organizations or groups like you know
hear stories about the battles that go
down in the boardroom at Apple or Google
or Amazon but if we did hear about them
yeah I'm sure some people that have
gotten cursed out and you know talked to
a certain way and somebody fired back
and say something back or whatever but
at the end of the day yes they still get
the job done they're still one of the
best companies in the world at whatever
they do so for me though that's what I
remember
I don't connect to like this one day
that feel had to say this to Kobe and
then Kobe said this back in it I just
don't because the goal was to win
championships and we got that done a lot
of time yes you did
Derek Fisher won't take a break back in
60 seconds talked to you about the
current NBA and then your experience
with the New York Knicks as a die-hard
Knick fan who has disowned the team you
need a hook rich well oh not only a
verbal of physical hug yes yes by the
way that is how this interview is going
and I'll give you that heads up but I
need I need it I need to hang my hat on
something here and and then we'll just
return to the dancing and send you on
your way okay back in 60 seconds with
Derek Fisher here on the Rich Eisen show
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show once
again Dancing with the Stars the season
25 holy crap 25 seasons of Dancing with
the Stars it premieres next Monday on
ABC at 8 p.m. Eastern Time and one of
the contestants is sitting right next to
me here and Derek Fisher
let's talk current Lakers if you don't
mind would Lonzo ball how do you think
he's gonna fare in this league well with
everything skillset off the court with
his dad in the expectation level and
maybe target on his back but some
veterans know I think I'm on the court I
mean we obviously have a long time to
wait and see I mean it he has the
potential obviously you have a great
first year as a rookie but it could be a
struggle this year and that doesn't
necessarily mean he's gonna have a bad
career so I think we still have to be
patient in terms of where he will be on
the court as his career on foes I lean
towards him being successful maybe not
to the degree of the hype that
everybody's placing on him but it it
takes there's it takes a skill you have
to have skill to manage the noise that
surrounds his life and his family's life
and how big they are when they walk in a
room and to me he kind of has that skill
like he knows kind of how to exist in
that will not be to be 10 flipping it
seems like he's he's been around noise
since his birth maybe the tune yeah and
in a way and with love honestly and and
love and respect his dad here the things
that maybe he says at times yeah but
then still be able to kind of live in
his own space and be his own young man
and not have to be like his dad but at
the same time it's my dad I love him
that's why I'm here so he to me he gets
all of that and that's a big part of
being successful and being the face of
the Lakers is you have to be able to
handle the noise because that comes with
yeah being one of the guys that the
Lakers are building around so and I
think some guys in recent years weren't
comfortable in that space what do you
think if do you think how do you think
magic would handle it if Lavar even
twitches about popping off about minutes
played coaching style anything like that
what do you think magic does no one no
one everybody that you do yeah you know
I think you know magic would in my
opinion that I can't speak for him that
would be a private conversation that
they would have at some point not to
reprimand or you can't tell another
grown man how to live and what he should
or shouldn't do or just a conversation
that to me any team president or
management should have with an employee
or a family member of an employee that
we're just we're trying to do business a
certain way actually to make your son's
job easier if we kept things in a
certain fashion to meet us type of
conversation you would want to have okay
what do you think of Kyrie saying I want
out of Cleveland and then getting those
exit papers and that trade between
Cleveland and the Celtics Derrick what'd
you think of that one I mean right now
it may not make sense to a lot of people
to want to leave you know they've been
to the finals three years in a row right
when you're on the bronze team you
probably are gonna be in the finals so
it may not make sense now but to me
Kyrie has always had that thing that
that puts him in the class of the
biggest stars in the game and and so he
feels like he's ready to step into that
now he's not by himself in Boston Gordon
Hayward am the basketball player and
he's you know been in Utah
been a franchise player as well but
there's Kyrie wants to be he wants to be
the guy that it all revolves around not
just in terms of shots and attempts but
that the pressure really is on him to
make sure that his team wins and I think
playing with LeBron for him he didn't
see himself getting that opportunity so
you know similar to Shaq and Kobe and
yeah and but we don't have to define
that as a negative thing I went when did
it turn into young men wanting to aspire
for more to achieve more well it's all
about team I mean I don't need to tell
hope that either and you're right you
know I mean it's about the team and you
know the Pat Riley disease of more right
yes that he always talks about yes but I
don't think that because you
individually want to do more that that
means that the team is less for example
when we won a championship in 2000 hmm I
came off the bench behind Ron Harper at
a different type of role on that
championship team that summer Kevin
Garnett Garnett and I were on the Jamie
Foxx show when he got a sitcom so I have
my my sag after card as well so so we're
having a conversation backstage yeah and
Kevin asked me fish what else do you
want to accomplish like you just want a
championship what else isn't in the
league you want to do and I said look I
love winning the championship but I want
more than that I want to be in the game
in the fourth quarter making the big
decisions and making the big shots
that's ultimately what ended up
happening because I've spoke it into
existence because that's what I wanted
to do but that didn't mean that the
Lakers are the team or Kobe or Shaq or
anybody next to me meant less it just
meant that I wanted more and to me
that's where Kyrie or anybody else is
saying when they make some of these
decisions it's not that my teammates
don't mean anything to me but why can't
I maximize my fullest potential and also
he own a great team and if you had said
that on an Instagram account back in
2000 look out it'd be different shows
like this this shows like you know yes
and that's a different side and a
different side of the business that
these guys are having to navigate and
some of them do it well some of them
yeah maybe not but I'm just proud of
these guys for continuing that to try
and do them and be them in the midst of
all of it and when you see where Russell
Westbrook in is doing and has been able
to do after the way he would
consistently get ridicule for being who
he is and how he plays and to be able to
like just continue to grow in all of
that and to become the MVP in and but to
be able to be in fashion and be a New
York Fashion Week and yes in balance the
commercials and all the things they'll
be attentive or being a new dad and the
husband and that that just says a lot
about to me the character and integrity
of these guys that sometimes we just try
to throw to the side Derek Fisher here
on the Rich Eisen show for a few more
minutes what what did happen in New York
City with the next where did it all go
wrong Derek um do you think yeah see
yeah I think you know the the
year-to-year circumstances and
situations are more symbolic of a larger
you know issue that has to continue to
be figured out as is and just like any
team in sports you have an ownership
group or owner you have management you
have coaches and players and unless
there is a 100% alignment in the vision
of how we're gonna have the greatest
football or basketball and in this case
basketball team and organization there's
not an alignment in those thoughts about
who we're gonna be as an organization
our mission statement our core
principles the type of people we want
working for us the type of guys we want
plan for us the style of play we want to
play that we feel like puts our players
in the best position to be successful if
all those things aren't aligned it does
not work so to me is not a just a Jim
Dolan thing or a Phil Jackson thing or a
Derek Fisher thing that's consistent
across the board in any spectrum if
there's not alignment in those things
you won't be successful you won't win so
where was this what happened with us
where was the lack of alignment I mean
cuz Dolan hired Phil who hired you okay
we're
the alignment go out of whack out of
that flow chart in your estimation I
just think they're really time wise you
know getting in alignment sometimes
takes more than 18 months so you know I
think in terms of alignment I personally
didn't spend a lot of time talking to
Jim Dolan about alignment of vision I
was hired as the coach my relationship
was more with feel okay um st. in that
much reaction interaction but James
Dolan and I not a lot he would come in
and say good luck
you know before games at the garden but
he you know he didn't pop into practices
regularly and throw his weight around as
the owner so I always felt like he
respected my space as the coach what
about Phil did he any pop in yeah Phil
was in the building regularly so he
would watch practice from his office or
come out onto the court and watch
practice and there's you know plenty of
on record statements about times when
maybe he would come in and want to say
some things or make a comment about what
was going on in court yeah and that was
a part of being in that environment and
what that didn't do much for lack of
success I mean they're just you know
there are a lot of reasons why teams
don't win and as a head coach
it ends up stopping at you and if you
don't win you lose your job sure you
take responsibility I understand that if
you don't mind I'm gonna take a couple
of shots at the Bulls out here can the
triangle work in the NBA in the 2017
2018 21st century I don't I don't know
if it can work the way we did it the
same way you can't teach 9th grade
algebra where you're used to 20 years
ago doesn't mean it's not algebra but
you just can't approach it the same the
kids are different the way they learn
and receive information is different I
personally think that the format of it
the spacing how to utilize different
players in different positions you can
utilize but then there are some things
you can do to make it a little more
difficult to guard based on the way
teams defend in the NBA now ok and did
Phil want the job as a team president I
mean did he really understand
the 24/7 365 aspect of it I mean it's
just he wanted the job I don't think he
would have taken a job if he didn't want
it you know you know he'll be an answer
that better than me
but I think of course is his energy was
really focused more about on the court
and I think Steve Mills as the general
manager was there to help execute a lot
of things in terms of the business and
the management aspect of it and so it
you know again I don't think everything
can be placed on field or on me or on
Steve Mills or on Carmelo or any one
person just as a group we didn't get it
done and we all have to take some
responsibility for it all right before I
let you go Ken too low our producer put
up on the screen and I'll read out for
Derek Fisher the oddsmakers
on the 2017 season 25 for Dancing with
the Stars
there is Nick Lachey at four to one yep
Debbie Gibson leads a trio at eight to
one mm-hmm Malcolm in the middle has
better odds than Derek Fisher is that
four is that true at nine to one that's
where this is I mean as I mean and then
there you are ten and one with Terrell
Owens and come on now yeah mount up in
the middle Frankie Muniz has been right
it's not new though not new no that's
not it's not new for me to have you know
Oh low odds but so a little I was in
comparison to the guy was in Malcolm in
the Middle and Frankie Muniz I would
think that that's a that's a new make so
you know he's been on TV as a performer
so will you know would you have to see
yeah as the season unfolds if those
numbers change that's my job good luck
to you sir
thank you at Derek Fisher on Twitter
Dancing with the Stars season 25
premieres next Monday at 8:00 Eastern
Time or back with more and more the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon
Eastern on radio stations across the
country
and audience if you like some of that
get some more of that on the Rich Eisen
show app follow all the information you
see right here on the Rich Eisen show